I'm not a scholar brother so I can't
exactly explain to you why there might
be a word missing versus a word not
missing no one can that's the point no
one
[Music]
can
hey this is brother everyy all right how
you doing brother doing good bro how are
your okay the brother you want every
want to say something to you I'm I'm
just I'm listening it sound like he said
it was like the the the the Quran are
the same yeah but now it sounds like
okay that there the message is the same
in all enti if you look at if you pick
up any Quran it's exactly the same these
are going to be different slightly
because it's a translation into a
different language right the original
language that the Quran was revealed in
is Arabic so if you look at the original
there's not a single there's not a
single version different the all the
Arabic is the same if there was would
that be a problem if there was different
Quran yeah yeah okay so cuz I think we
have examples of that there is no
different do you know Arabic at
all have you heard of the like Huffs and
warsh stuff like that that is yeah I've
heard of that that's not a different
Quran brother that's um in terms of like
reciting okay so it's in the text though
it's written no no no it's um to
understand that it's like U let me see
no no I can tell you because I memorized
the book so hofs worsh and like those
I'm not like 1,000% familiar but because
I've memorized the the book I've like
come into uh contact with these type of
things you're familiar with it yeah I'm
familiar with it so the only difference
is in terms of the pronunciation right
but it's not it's the text no no it's in
terms of pronunciation for example um
brother there are literally words
missing in some of them no no but that's
because of the pronunciation bro no you
can't pronounce a word that's not there
but that's the that's the uh core
differences of the hff's wor thing is
what is the differences in pronunciation
so what happened if a word is missing
what what happens if one has a word
that's in the part of a sentence and the
other one doesn't have that word can you
give me an example of that yeah yeah so
if we go to I you got have to do the
number there's no there's not going to
be a huff Quran and a wor Quan this is
this is what we're looking at this is
the this is the H that's the war but
that's they're all the same though okay
so I'm going to show you look so if you
go to uh 57 CH 57:
24 and are you talking about the Arabic
word yeah yeah yeah no no English L cuz
I understand like so I could probably
help you out with yeah that's perfect if
so maybe you can help this with this
with this one too I I can't go through
the numbers and Sh I I don't know Arabic
however I do know 57 ver 24 24 yeah or
it might be 23 in in yourk version if
you can you go to chapter 57 in this one
verse
24 uh
yes
5724 oh nice this one has the numbers y
oh but this one doesn't have the English
numbers oh but here it is right okay
good all right so let's let's all right
you hold this one okay so this is the
this is the Huffs okay so this is 24
yeah verse 24 down here
okay
so so notice how Bo so the only
difference bro haa means like him he is
yeah so I mean that's not like the
entirety of the message the exact same
the only difference would be um in terms
of specific see brother I get what
you're saying see what you're saying is
that the the message or the the context
doesn't change the same from my
understanding bro I'm not a scholar but
from my understanding I'll give you an
example H and wor right let me let me
just finish just to give you really
quick Arabic you say
alhamd right that's HS for wor it might
be alhamdulillah hey yeah but that's the
same word it's the same word right this
this majority of the differentiation
between the Hops and the wor in terms of
pronunciation it's not that's what I'm
showing you I'm showing you that that
the claim that there's there's not
difference in the
text your one word let me say this let
me let me say this okay the the
important thing is that okay if you're
saying that at first you were saying
that there's no difference in the text
it's only oral like only recitation
which I understand what you're saying
yeah however that's not true cuz we see
that there's a literal word that's gone
so it has nothing to do with oral
recitation it has to do with the text
you know what I'm saying so there's
differences textually not just how we
pronounce a certain word but words are
gone in some in some uh examples you
know what I'm saying so if there's a
textural difference not just simply oral
then this will show that there's a
textual difference because if you look
at the meaning of that one if if a word
is gone and yeah bro but it doesn't
change the meaning does it okay so now
you're changing your position no I'm not
changing my position my my position is
that the message is the exact same even
with textual variance yes even if look
look if you read the translation of this
one and then the translation of that one
the only textual V variance you're going
to see is he is versus directly not
mentioning he is but they were probably
already AG so the my my my principle is
that the message does not change May
I'm not too sure exactly why that is but
that's not going to be enough for me to
say that my entirety of my religion is
is not complete because why why because
I look at I have other examples okay but
I look if you look just think about it
with the open mind right about it with
an open mind too brother look I'm
telling you right now I with what you're
saying with the position that yeah there
can be textual variance but if if the
message or the context is still intact
then you're still good to go we believe
the same thing as Christians we have
textual variance in with when it comes
to the Bible there's people that believe
in the
Trinity believe in the trity with
Muslims again you have Muslims over
there ahed Muslims they don't believe
Muhammad is the last messenger there
there there is I'm not going to lie to
you there's there's Shia Muslims there's
Ahi Muslims there's different kinds yeah
there's different everybody has
different different dority the majority
is like all the same and the same with
us the the majority are trinitarian
Christians that's Orthodoxy because a l
what do you mean that's not true and you
go to a certain place they might be all
Catholic right they're trinitarians they
might be all uh what's the other one see
you're just talking about different
denominations at this point but they're
all still trinitarian Christians okay so
you're a Christian right yes so what
makes you so sure of your religion okay
so I just just to be sure about this to
L this point is that we see that with
the Quran there are there are different
versions We have to be able to admit
that there's different version there's
no different versions in terms of the
meaning in terms of principles there are
though I can show you this is you want
me to show you you just showed me one
and Chang no I I no I showed you that
there was a textual a difference right
I'm going to show you that I'm going
show you a text of difference that
changes the meaning there you can find
any variation of the Quan you want to
see it no listen there's you can find
any variation of the Quan you're not
going to find a single one with a
different message than the other can I
show you yes okay do you have the Hamza
one no I don't have you don't have of
course you don't you don't
have
huh uh that's a
little people can play around with that
but yes we can show that
one but we can play around people can
play around with that one which one is
that one that the creation is what does
it say creation what does it say though
I don't know this
one me read him so you mind if I show
you online cuz I we don't have the we
have this but we don't have the Quran
that I'm talking about I'm not going to
like nitpick at like that okay you got
to you got to bring to me something
that's like substantial you know what I
mean if you're going to talk about like
one word here missing versus another
word it's not really substantial I
understand why that might cause is
substantial it's substantial based on
what you were saying it's not
substantial in terms of changing the
meaning I agree if but if your if your
position is there's no Quran that's
different textually then this is
substantial right if you have the
position that there's differences in the
text but the context is the same that's
fine I I can't exactly I'm not a scholar
brother so I can't exactly explain to
you why there might be a word missing
versus a word not missing no one can
that's the point no one can can you
recite this
one okay what's that mean I don't
know I don't
knowa means the fight fight the F okay
so I'm going to give you this one here
now you're going to
so it says many a prophets fought many
Prophet yeah that it's the same word the
word the same letters it's the same word
yeah but the meaning is
changed yeah one is fought one is killed
okay so you have a difference in meaning
is one says many of many of prophets
fought the other one says many of
prophets were killed
ukra so which one's
right the only difference in this
brother if you understand like U how to
read the Arabic language is this is
Again part of the pronunciation of the
word the both words are the same but
it's the terms of connecting the it's a
ktl right
K like imagine K is stretched out T is
stretched out L is stretched out right
in one version k t l they're all
stretched out and one vers K connects to
T
so and
then that changes it that changes the
meaning but it's in terms of
pronunciation I understand but it's
notice how the DI critical Mark changes
the entire word like in Arabic like a DI
critical Mark will change the word right
and so we have kattila and ktil one is
fight or fought one is killed those are
two different things can you okay um you
know what I'm saying what is like okay
what is your proof to me that why do you
believe Christianity is like uh proof is
true for me it's prophecy like so you
have the pro like this is something that
I think we can agree on is that the
prophets bring one message right they
they came with the message pray worship
on God but it was more than that too the
prophets pointed to the messiah's coming
and so when they're talking about the
coming of Jesus we can see like in the
scriptures them describe what happens to
him when he comes his birthplace all
this kind of stuff showing that God
really did speak to these people right
so like for example if um um we believe
that we believe that too bro you believe
in prop right in the Bible it's also
mentioned about Muhammad well it's not
that's that's that's that's what the
Quran claims but that's not true the
Quran doesn't claim that it does the
Quran brother the Quran in ch 7:1 157 it
says they can find the unlettered
prophet written in the Torah and the
gospel so it says that we can find him
in our scriptures but he's not there we
believe in him you believe but he's not
believe in Jesus we believe Jesus was a
prophet but you but that's that he's
that's he's more than that he's the word
of God he's the son of God the Messiah
well we don't believe in the Son of God
but we definitely believe he was a
prophet of God we believe he was
delivering God's message and the way we
believe it is that before Islam there
was another religion Islam is the what
we understand I'm telling you my belief
Islam is the final version okay so
before this Jesus came and he presented
his uh his thing and I believe there was
another Prophet that who had the Ten
Commandments right Moses Moses so those
also came from God but there were
different versions right because as time
progress different prophets were sent
but we believe that all the prophets
were sa from the same person Moses was
same sent from the same person he had
his own
message had his own message but we
believe that Muhammad came and he
presented his message as the conclusion
of the religion now now my question to
you would be how would you know that
Muhammad's message is in line with Jesus
or Moses how would you be able to know
this they're not exactly the same no but
I know they're not be exactly the same
but in line like for example I know that
Muhammad comes at a particular time his
message has to be in line with what came
before right I mean if we look at
principles Jesus did uh in terms of
Christianity because the is bro right
now we have St Paul and all these things
but if you look at Christian
Christianity's message of Jesus jesus'
message was to worship the Creator right
that's what Paul taught as well yeah but
how do you know that Muhammad's message
is in line with Jesus cuz Jesus taught
he's the son got to go bro it was nice
to meet you man name Avery Avery yes sir
man manran Manan nice to have a dope
name man yeah I like what you guys had a
talk bro um if anything bro I would just
say um keep an open mind bro an
right I've read the bro I would say just
look into Islam a little bit I have dude
I've
read I've talked to a lot I don't know
if they're the right ones but I talked
to shakes I just talked to Mom last week
they weren't able to like uh they're not
able to give me sufficient reasons why
Islam is true or really the the problems
that I bring up you know and it's not
that I'm bringing them up like haha
gotcha but it's like genuine how do you
how do you how would you guys fix this
or solve this and there's there I
haven't been given nothing sufficient
okay to be honest what are like some
topics you you struggle with in terms of
Islam yeah for sure my my biggest
problem with Islam is what the Quran
says about the previous scriptures the
Bible the Torah and the gospel so like
it says that it came confirming it we
can find Muhammad mentioned in it um you
know we have to judge by the Torah and
the gospel right but at the same time
when I put them side by side the Quran
says really different things than what
the Torah and gospels say like for
example Jesus being the Son of God Jesus
being crucified the Quran neglects all
of that so it's confirming a book that
it contradicts and that's the problem no
the thing is boss um like I said when it
comes to Christianity there's a lot of
different versions right no there is no
there's one Christianity man there's one
Christianity but you got cath you got
people in uh you have different
denominations but it's still
Christianity yeah just like how you were
showing me like the little different
words right okay for example ktl versus
Catal
yeah yeah that in the Bible you're going
to find much much larger significant
differences than that what dude we
didn't even scratch the surface between
the different Bibles St Paul St John
there is no different Bibles of St Paul
or John dude there is the letter look
look let me just show you the letters of
Paul are all they're all in the same
book okay the Bible is a collection of
all these writings okay John's writings
Paul's writings all this stuff okay
that's collection of different people's
writings of their observance of Jesus
right not just their observance but
their the inspiration of God for them to
write what they wrote Jesus says that
he's going to send the holy spirit to
guide them into all truth and to bring
to their remembrance what he taught them
so what they're writing is inspired by
God to write what they wrote including
Paul I'm telling you man it's it's it's
a lot but it's it's all the
misconceptions can be cleared up I
promise you have you have you read read
the gospel before no I haven't you
haven't man check it out I read the H
you want a Bible not um how you going to
read it if you don't have a Bible I'm
sure my religion boss but but your
religion tells you to read the gospel no
it doesn't brother My Religion give me
give me where's the Quran give me the my
religion is Islam right we follow we
follow the prophet and his message his
message is the Quran and Muhammad tells
you to to believe in the gospel yeah I
believe in the gospel but you have to
read it you can't believe in something
you don't know about the thing is that
I'm talking about is these are different
versions right versions of what of
because the gospel wasn't Islam the
gospel was a different religion I agree
right so it's not current to me it is
current to you no because I am of the
generations of the Prophet Muhammad no
he's 1400 years ago yeah but the way we
look at the way in Islam how we talk
about it is because there's no Prophet
after Muhammad so he's the last prophet
so he's the prophet that's what we say
about Jesus Jesus is the Seal of the
prophets the he says this the he says
the prophets
that Muhammad because so Muhammad tells
you to follow the gospel as well no he
doesn't mhammad says to follow thean let
me let me show you man look I know you
got to go so I'll just show you this
okay look and there's the call just
really quick this is this is important
what chapter all right let's go to
the
okay I'm getting confused here does this
go left to right or right to left it
goes left to right
okay more I do believe in the gospel bro
I'm not denying that the gospel doesn't
exist then but if you don't believe in
then you got to read it uh I haven't
read the gospel so look brother look
this is chapter 10:94 so if you are in
doubt oh Muhammad about that which we
have revealed to you talking about the
Quran then ask those who have been
reading the scripture before you the
truth has certainly come to you from
your lord so never be among the doubters
so if Muhammad ever had a doubt about
the Quran Allah tells him hey go check
the previous scriptures you'll be all
right he said to check with as those who
have been reading the scripture before
you that's the Bible yeah so that's the
thing I believe in the Bible bro do you
read it no because there's too many
editions uh edits there's too many Ed
there's not what come on man there's a
lot of edits you look it up in the in
online or anything bro there's a lot of
edits in the Bible there's not a single
Bible that
if you're talking if you're talking
about these if you're talking about
these criticism look your your
criticisms that you're bringing against
the Bible if that's why you rejected
yeah then you have to reject the Quran
no I don't reject uh Christianity due to
the Bible you just the reasons you're
saying are because there's
differences um Christianity I believe
Christianity um was a
religion and I'm not a scholar bro so
you can't you can't like take my words
and be like this is this is Islam right
you know what I mean I'm I'm not one to
talk in the first place so I'm just
talking to you having a conversation I'm
not like a scholar where what I say is
Authority yeah right I I still have a
lot to learn myself I'm not like the
perfect Muslim either but I'm just
telling you from what I
know look look look into it if if the
the the the Bible was so important that
Allah pointed Muhammad back to it if he
ever doubted the Quran yeah you know
what I'm saying the Bible is the
verifier of the Quran whether it's true
or not so if the Quran is not in line
with the teachings in the previous
scripture then the Quran is false we
have good reason to doubt that's not
that's not exactly true bro that's what
it says here do the Ten Commandments
came and then Christianity came and then
Islam came so they're all different each
one has different they were brought to
different people right but you at one
time at one time like all these prophets
they were sent to different people right
different generation ations or different
people or different areas okay right so
they were brought with the mission to
guide the people of that time not just
of that time of the ones who would come
after too why why do you think Mo
Moses's law The Ten Commandments lasted
all the way until Jesus until Jesus that
and even and even until now the Ten
Commandments still stand so you have
where God gives a law for even
Generations later for people to uphold
to you know what I'm saying so we
believe that as to be the Quran because
as Muslims we believe that the Quran is
our book and Muhammad is our last
Messenger right how do you know that
it's in line if I was born in the time
before Muhammad then I would follow
Jesus brother I know what you're saying
my question is how do you verify that
what Muhammad brought in this Quran is
actually in line with the prophets sence
science okay science and religion and
thean it goes together so what if
there's a scientific mistake in the
America is yeah there is no there isn't
the okay what was created first
theh no that creation of the human
being scientifically explained in the
Quran before we had any like uh
embryologist what was created first the
heavens of the
earth uh I'm not too sure the universe
is like is older than the earth UK the
Quran says that the Earth was created
before the the universe that's a
scientific
impossibility Victory win not exactly
what do you mean not exactly brother I'm
not sure exactly what you're talking
about bro oh look what I'm saying is is
that but I got to go to be honest oh
yeah I do want to continue a
conversation but I do got to go yeah
take care of you don't let me hold you
up man I appreciate it that's a good bro
I suggest you also keep an open mind and
if you're open minded read the gospel I
will I definitely will all right I'll
take your word for the only thing I
would ask you bro is figure out what
your um
what are your like main things that make
you question Islam brother I have I have
them all take take those to somebody I
did I do it every day and they
didn't I I have a YouTube channel where
I literally do this you know what I'm
saying I do this all the time I talk to
Muslims imams shakes I do this y I'm
coming where are
you
okay all right bro take take care man
bye boy Quran everybody
subscribe oh my God logic
[Music]